Speaker 1: Mitt Romney is blasting Marjorie
Taylor GREENE on her secession insanity. We're
going to look at a short clip. Remember that
Marjorie Taylor GREENE last week said that we
need a national divorce where we divide up into
red states and blue states. I told you all of
the reasons why that makes no sense. Senator
Mitt Romney, a Republican, was asked about it
and here's what he had to say. Senator, what do
you think about Representative Marjorie Taylor?
GREENE this call on social media for a national
to divorce dividing the country. Republican
and Democrat Democratic states. You know, I
think Abraham Lincoln dealt with that kind of
insanity. We're not going to divide the country.
It's united. We stand, divided we fall. Yeah,
listen, I didn't vote for Mitt Romney, but he does
seem like a fundamentally decent and honest guy
who just tells you what he thinks. And he thinks a
lot of modern Republicanism is completely insane.
Now, I've told you the two main reasons why this
entire separate into two countries won't work. The
first is the unconstitutionality of unilateral
secession. Now, maybe Marjorie. Maybe Marjorie
Taylor GREENE is talking about a version where,
like, everybody agrees. Everybody's like, No,
you're like Oklahoma. You should go. Go do
your own thing. But the Constitution of the
United States, which is the supreme law of the
land, doesn't provide a provision for secession.
And in fact, the idea of secession arguably was
tested in the Civil War. Supreme Court has ruled
you can't just secede. States can't just say we
secede. It's not a legal option for any state.
If you attempt to do it, you would be violating
the Constitution and Supreme Court rulings. Now,
the second part of it is that the red states
aren't viable as a country. And I know that
if you watched last week's show, you already
know this. But I do want to get it into this
clip as well. The red state country that would be
created is fundamentally not viable economically.
And this is for a number of different reasons.
GDP per capita is much lower in red states than
blue states. Red states are disproportionately
subsidized with federal funding that comes from
blue states which overwhelmingly pay money in
rather than get money out. Blue states, on average
have more diverse economies, whereas red states
often depend on one industry or product or sector.
So it's very at risk to that one. You know, oil in
Texas or agriculture in Kansas. So that makes the
economies generally more vulnerable to economic
fluctuations. There are, on average, more educated
people in the blue states. That leads to higher
paying jobs and more innovation. There's better
infrastructure as a result in the blue states.
Education and access to health care tend to be
better, which also makes it more attractive for
businesses. It's a vicious cycle, and right now,
to a great degree, the red states are being pulled
up by all of these aspects of blue states. If
you've just got red states as a country, it really
wouldn't work well at all. And Mitt Romney just
pointing out that it makes no sense for a number
of reasons. Good for Mitt Romney. I wish there
were more Republicans willing to stand up and just
say these these people shouldn't be here. Marjorie
Taylor GREENE is a disaster. Mitt Romney went
up to George Santos, George Anthony to Boulder
Santos during the State of the Union and said, I'm
shocked you're even here. You should be ashamed.
If we had more Republicans like Mitt Romney, the
Republican Party would be just a party would we
disagree with on policy and less of the scourge or
scourge on the United States that it has become?